living in limbo Palestinian refugees in
Lebanon say they are fed up
with watching the escalating violence in
occupied territories in Al-Aqsa mosque
Gaza and the West Bank
watching their people suffer indignities
at the hands of Israelis from a distance
and from a country whose own economy is
in tatters
we don't live in Palestine but Palestine
lives inside us
every day we sit without you and we talk
about Palestine about Freedom about our
history and our right to go back
war is necessary what was taken by force
should be taken back by force peace did
not work
displaced for decades people living here
are connected to the conflict by history
by Blood and by their circumstances
have never been to Palestine but I know
about it from my family all the attacks
happening make me feel like it belonged
to the nation even more
I was born here but I am Palestinian and
loyal to the Palestinian cause what's
happening is totally unjust we are very
upset and sad but we can't do anything
we can't help we watch how Israelis
attack Al-Aqsa mosque and we can't do
anything
Generations displaced and generations
born abroad yet to set foot on their
ancestral lands
with every passing year Whenever there
is an escalation of tension and violence
between Israelis and Palestinians for
the thousands of people living in
refugee camps like this the hope of
going back home a right of return is
something that slips away just a little
bit more
and to remain here is to live as some of
the poorest people in Lebanon
Zain basavi al-jazeera at the Burj
al-barajne refugee camp in Beirut